baltimore ravens ended up winning the
afc north last year and had the number
one seed in the afc until they lost at
home in the divisional round of the
tennessee titans
has
any of the other three teams managed to
close the gap
on the baltimore ravens that is the
subject
of this segment chris and look i i
i i look at what the ravens have done
and i think the real question is how
much bigger have the ravens made the gap
between them and everyone else they are
not
resting on their laurels not that they
ultimately were able to get a trophy
last year but they had great success and
they are not waiting for the other teams
to catch them when you look at what
they've done this off season how they've
tried to make their team better i really
do think the gap may be bigger
i agree
between them and the other three teams
well i i mean a hundred percent you know
i think we could sit here and if you
talk about like the teams who won the
off season in the nfl this year the
baltimore ravens are in the conversation
for some of the things they did in free
agency in the draft they they killed the
draft you know and free agency to be
able to sign us campbell you know get
back jimmy smith keep matt judon that
was a huge signing you know
uh
they franchised him so they did a lot of
good things just there as far as keeping
their core together in baltimore and
adding to leia's campbell but then you
look at their draft and what they did
there you know getting a two middle
linebackers in the first three rounds
getting a difference maker and jk
dobbins at at running back another
defensive tackle another receiver uh
that you know and duvernay from texas
that that lamar jackson could throw to
so i'm with you mike i mean i i think
baltimore is one of the teams i would
sit here and go they had the best
offseason in all of football so i'm not
sure if anybody please close the gap if
there's any team in the division that
closed the gap at all to me it would be
the cleveland browns they're another
team that i think like baltimore killed
free agency and killed the draft as well
to at least improve their football team
and the browns have yet another new head
coach and kevin stefanski i know that
for some on this program maybe both of
us there were questions about why
stefanski and why not josh mcdaniels
instead given that mcdaniels would come
from that patriot way would instill that
patriot way but the browns look they
finally have gotten aligned under paul d
podesta and they've let him basically
call the shots on the head coach in the
gm they've added some great players
signed jack conklin away from the titans
he had a great year last season at right
tackle a guy who didn't have his option
picked up but then had a great contract
year and left tennessee signed tight end
austin hooper away from the atlanta
falcons used the 10th overall pick on
jedrick wills to further beef up that
offensive line that you know has still
not fully recovered from the retirement
of joe thomas and when you look at what
nick chubb did last year almost winning
the rushing title it was a late push
from derek henry of the titans that took
it away from chubb what baker mayfield
did as a rookie what maybe he could do
in year three if they can just get
things stabilized chris your guy obj had
a video yesterday where he has boasted
he's gonna have one of his best seasons
ever now that he's gotten himself
healthy we'll see
but uh yeah i think of the three teams
steelers browns bengals the browns and
and i i don't know that this is good
news for the browns to not be
off the radar screen i feel like the
more focus and attention that we put on
the browns the harder it is for them to
live up to the hype and the expectations
the hype isn't like it was last year but
i still think that maybe the team is
better than it was last year
i do too i think it's you know it's more
well-rounded you know last year it was a
lot of you know sex appeal oh you know
it's it's so it's olivier vernon we got
him and baker mayfield and obj and
jarvis landry and we're going to be you
know the greatest show on turf and yeah
that you know listen we're all excited
about that definitely and the fact that
kareem hunt's there and they kept him
alive with nick chubb but the thing i
would be the most excited about is what
you talked about what they did on really
the offensive line jack conklin and then
to get jedrick wills in the top 10 of
the draft so now you have two franchise
tackles to go with you know a pretty
good interior offensive line mike and
let's not forget nick chubb was you know
did he lead the league in rushing last
year so they can run block a little bit
derrick derrick henry
in the last week yeah that's right i
forgot right so you know there's there's
a lot to like there and then one of the
issues you know you looked at on their
defensive side of the ball last year we
know they have some you know athletic
studs on the edge of the defense but to
sign an adrian claiborne and then andrew
billings uh and then a few guys in the
secondary too just to kind of round out
that defense to help out the safety
position give them some bigger bodies
you know make the run defense better
yeah i like what cleveland did this off
season you know yeah i wasn't a huge fan
of the stefanski hiring um but but you
know mike will you and i will be the
first one to sit here if they start
tearing it up to go look at him he did a
great job and i'm rooting for him it's
nothing personal uh it's certainly not
but i like what cleveland's done and i
think you know they're they're heading
in the right direction there's no doubt
the bengals got quarterback joe burrow
number one overall andy dalton was cut
last week so they go with borough they
bring in
receiver t higgins in round two
franchise tag applied to aj green joe
mixon still there entering the fourth
year of his career and has been not
spectacular but i guess given the
constraints of the bengals offense he's
been better than than average much
better than average really david carr
uh who went through
uh the early stages of a career with the
texans without having much help on the
offensive line he recently expressed you
know an opinion that hey joe burrow
is in for a long rookie season if they
don't improve the offensive line i think
that's the real question in cincinnati
do they have enough protection to let
burro do all those great things that he
did at lsu chris
yeah well you know there there's two
things there let's not forget their
first round pick from alabama he'll be
back in the lineup next year and tackle
all right you know you didn't get left
out again
it's funny how all the guys who come
back from injury just assume they're
going to play 16 games i'd love to see
the stats on that but but but you're if
he's healthy if he's healthy that'll
help
right i mean it's certainly going to be
an upgrade to what they had in a hole
still the greatest thing about joe
burrow mike that we talked about during
the draft burroughs amazing under
pressure that's one of the positive
things about him and you mentioned you
know joe mixon i would think there's
going to be real emphasis on getting
that run game going he's a special
running back you know that's hey that
falls on the the guideline of hey it's a
team sport and it stinks because you
could be one of the best at your
position in a sport and if nobody's
opening up holes for you or doing
anything to help you we don't know about
it and that's what stinks but they do
have aj greenback made some you know
adjustments to their secondary thought
they got a great defensive tackle and dj
reader from the texans uh i thought that
was a huge pickup for their football
team but you know the bengals are
they're headed in the right direction no
doubt i mean hey listen i i'm a huge fan
of joe burrow and i think that t higgins
second round pick uh is gonna fit real
nicely with his style of play too so
they're trending upward there's no doubt
about that it's just gonna be a big year
for zach taylor getting joe burrow
caught up in this offense and get
everything going that way
joe mixon quietly had
1137 rushing yards last year which
actually ended up being
two more yards than dalvin cook now cook
missed a couple of games due to injury
late in the season i think one was more
let's just protect him the haze in the
barn on our playoff berth but still he
had more rushing yards than dalvin cook
with a team that was a far cry from the
minnesota vikings so you know mixing may
explode to the extent that there is a
threat in the passing game that pushes
that extra safety out of the box gives
joe mixon maybe a better running lane
but it is going to come down chris to
the offensive line can jonah williams be
healthy can the rest of the offensive
line do what it needs to do we haven't
mentioned the pittsburgh steelers look
if they have ben roethlisberger back
healthy all year long which could be a
big if given that he exited week two
with a season-ending elbow injury
but they've brought in chase clay pool
to beef up the receiving core they've
added anthony mcfarland jr to help out
with
a
multi-headed running attack that still
can't quite replace le'veon bell their
defense got really good last year you
know the steelers could be a team that
kind of quietly uh gives the ravens a
run for their money and just we know the
history in pittsburgh we know the mike
tomlin coaching we know everything about
pittsburgh they they are not going to
just give up they are not going to just
go see 10 and can concede anything to
anyone they're going to be in the thick
of things
no exactly i mean yeah we're not trying
to disrespect the pittsburgh steelers i
mean i think yeah we almost gloss them
over because we just go they're going to
be good they're going to be really
competitive they have a super bowl type
defense i mean come on what they did
last year the the last half of the year
the last 10 games of the year that was
amazing i mean they knew that they were
going to have to come out and hold teams
to 13 16 points or they couldn't win
games and they did that so first off
them keeping bud dupree you know through
the franchise franchise tag was huge for
their football team it was but this team
in a lot of ways like you mentioned is
built and ready to go yeah they add a
few guys in free agency eric ebron at
tight end that'll be a nice uh match
with ben rossenberg robles berger chase
clay pulling you know again some young
receivers that i think are gonna open up
some eyes with everybody this year uh
with deontay johnson and i think
washington james washington he'll be a
year better at all that so i certainly
am not trying to disrespect the steelers
i don't think you are either i think we
both look at them and go we think
they're going to be a major player in
the afc playoff conversation
they got a lot of fairly high round
picks at receiver in pittsburgh now
let's see if those guys step up we know
juju smith schuster can we're looking to
we're going to look and see what chase
claypool can do but when you've got
deontay johnson who's yet to really get
it done james washington yet to prove he
can do it on a high level we're going to
learn a lot about the steelers receivers
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports